pop depuis dimanche
alger à ces barricades trois jours sont
passés barricades devant la grand'poste
barricades aux facultés tout un quartier
d'alger est fermé comme le café d'ortiz
qui porte un nom prestigieux le fera
le pc d'ortiz c'est maintenant plutôt ce
premier étage face au plateau des
glières
d'où ses lieutenants d'heure en heure
harangue la foule des algérois
[Musique]
de là l'ex cafetiers tient tête avec la
gaillarde au gouvernement et aux lois de
son pays depuis le drame cette fusillade
que certains disent prémédité et qui fit
dimanche soir 20 morts et 140 blessés
justement ce matin se sont déroulés avec
simplicité les obsèques des gendarmes
mobiles
les six émeutiers ont tu leurs
sépultures hier tous ces deuils et
l'ampleur du drame n'ont fait
qu'accentuer le trouble des esprits
l'insurrection y trouve ses forces le
fossé s'élargit entre alger et paris
deux jours passent et encore
le délégué général el commandante en
chef ont quitté alger pour un pc à
l'écart de la ville ils sont à reghaïa
l'une des bases opérationnelles de
l'algérois ou leur liberté de
commandement sera assurée
[Musique]
car ces conditions le drame est arrivé à
son paroxysme dans la nuit d'alger ce
soir de vendredi
tout le monde attend aux barricades
comme dans les postes de garde insurgés
et militaires tout le monde attend d'une
même attente le discours que doit
prononcer le général de gaulle
paul parle j'ai pris au nom de la france
la décision que voici les algériens
disposent rang et librement de leur
destin or deux catégories de gens ne
veulent pas de ce libre choix
d'abord l'organisation rebelle qui
prétend ne cessez le feu que signe au
préalable je tête avec elle par
privilège de l'avenir politique de
l'algérie cela je ne le ferai pas
d'autre part certains français de souche
exige que je renonce à
l'autodétermination que je dise que tout
est fait que le sort des algériens est
d'ores et déjà décidé seul à ne plus je
ne le ferai pas mais alors pour imposer
à la france allait tard à moi-même leurs
prétentions
certains agissante entre est en
insurrection
ils ont tiré sur le service d'ordre
ils ont tué de bon soldat il se dresse
en armes contre l'autorité de la france
je dis à tous les soldats français
votre mission ne comporte aucune
équivoque et aucune interprétation
c'est moi qui porte le destin du pays
deux soldats français doivent donc mme
aubry
les paroles sont éteintes le lendemain
on les écoute encore on les écoute dans
le réduit fortifiée autour duquel tout
d'un coup une étreinte de l'armée se
resserre plus de place sur le plateau
des glières pour les manifestations
quotidiennes
c'est maintenant un no man's land
ceinture et de camions et de troupes les
insurgés cèderont thiais ils ont dit non
ils ont dit non et lance avec leur refus
des appels auxquels les foules d'alger
dans ce climat passionnel ne sont pas
insensibles
le passage interdit elle s'infiltre par
les toits et par les balcons vers le
réduit des insurgés
[Musique]
elle pousse contre les barrages et
parfois les barrages cède c'est alors
une grande ruée vers la barricade
derrière laquelle deux trois mille
hommes en armes sont enfermés depuis
maintenant six jours
[Musique]
manche arrive même poussé même effort et
ce dans le bruit d'une bombe
attentat fln trois parachutistes tués
dont on ramasse les débris semble
et
la foule algéroise ce n'est pas tout de
même le peuple d'alger c'est une foule
sensible irraisonnée instinctive qui
suit des mots d'ordre sonores dont elle
ne vérifie pas tout le sens elle trouve
sur sa route des barrages
elle pousse les barrages la troupe réagi
la foule recommence
parfois un trou se fait un flot passe et
puis la barrière se reconstituent et
tout reprend
[Musique]
mais il y a derrière cette agitation un
fait est énorme
l'armée a retrouvé son esprit et alger
n'est plus tout entier avec les
émeutiers
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'algérie le calme est
totalement rétabli à oran le discours du
général de gaulle à ramener l'apaisement
samedi autour du général dambielle la
population s'est rassemblée dans une
large manifestation d'unanimité
patriotique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et dimanche des foules ont fait le
pittoresque pèlerinage de santa cruz qui
du haut de son rocher semble protégé or
[Musique]
lundi la france entière manifeste par un
temps d'arrêt de travail
le soutien qu'elle apporte à la ligne de
conduite du président de la république a
réparé tout pour 10 minutes ou pour une
les centrales syndicales et les
organisations ouvrières sont d'accord
sur la politique algérienne du
gouvernement
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
dans alger la vie a repris sur l'ordre
du général crespin les boutiques ont
ouvert la grève a cessé on attend
deux nouvelles unités ceinture le réduit
arrive-t-on à la minute de vérité
[Musique]
et soudain c'est la fin des insurgés
s'attaque à la barricade loup
le silence et drapeaux en tête les
insurgés en armes sortent de leurs
bastions
ils seront dirigés vers les unités
combattantes
avec sort la gaillarde c'est fini
et parce que son est fini de l'aventuré
qu'il ya dans les aventures fini un
espoir et un commencement
peut-être faut-il chercher derrière ce
tragique épisode et dans les paroles du
général de gaulle le vrai sens que donne
la france à ses dessins est à césar nous
combattons en algérie une rébellion qui
dure depuis plus de cinq ans la france
poursuit courageusement l'effort
nécessaire pour la vague mais janot
aboutir à une paix qui soit à la paix de
telle sorte que le drame ne puisse pas
recommencer et de manière à ce que l
algérie en fin de compte ne soit pas
perdu ce qui serait un désastre pour
nous et pour l'occident
je m'adresse d'abord à la communauté de
souche française en algérie
elle me connaît depuis bien longtemps
que deux fois
je me suis trouvé au milieu tel et
notamment pendant la guerre ont un grand
nombre de cfi servait dans l'armée de la
libération ou bien après la secousse de
mai 58
quand j'ai pris la tête de la france
pour rétablir l'unité française de part
et d'autre de la méditerranée s vouloir
perdre l'algérie que d'y envoyer d'y
maintenir une armée de cinq cent mille
hommes pourvu d'un matériel énorme d'y
consentir à la mort de nombre de nos
enfants que l'action de développement
des populations musulmanes entamé depuis
18 mois activement pour
en ce moment et qui après la
pacification devrait s'épanouir encore
temps précisément à créer des liens
innombrables et nouveau entre la france
et les algériens et dans cette création
continue
où trouve-t-on la place de l'armée
gabonaise a liquidé la forces rebelles
qui voudraient chasser la france de
l'algérie et y instaurer sa dictature de
terreur de misère et de stérilité du
parmesan à l'action des armes nous avait
à contribuer au développement matériel
ou moral des populations musulmanes à
les attirer à la france par le choeur
ils parlent a raison et quand le moment
sera venu de procéder à la consultation
vous aurez à garantir qu'elle soit libre
et qu'elle soit sincère
depuis je m'adresse à la france
eh bien mon cher et vieux pays nous
voilà donc encore une fois ensemble
devant une jours d'épreuves une fois de
plus j'appelle tous les français quel
qu'il soit gilles soir
à se réunir à la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]